just do it do it
shia labeouf 2012 hey everyone my name
is matt bellows i and this is whine
about it a weekly video series where i
get drunk at my desk and complain about
stuff on this week's episode reasons
mornings are the absolute worst because
morning people were created by the devil
to spread sin and evil and I'll never be
awake enough to deal with that [ __ ]
but first let's drink oh that's a strong
one oh that's alright
first of all mornings are just a daily
reminder that I have responsibilities
that I have to take care of which I
spend a lot of time trying to forget
about every time my alarm clock goes off
it's just like beep beep you have a job
beep beep you have bills to pay
beep beep you have a drinking problem
that your mom keeps telling you you
should seriously consider addressing but
you just don't feel like it I just don't
need that kind of pressure in my life
before my eyes or even open why can't I
a ganache over all my life problems at
like 3 p.m. instead there's cruel and
unusual punishment to expect me to be
awake and presentable to the world
moments after I get out of bed I barely
pee in the toilet well over face the
[ __ ] world
next the human body just isn't built for
mornings alright not this one you ever
see what I look like in the morning
my breath smells my hair is [ __ ] and
my eyes look like the bottom of an empty
jar of grape jelly just raw like a goopy
newborn baby my body isn't ready to
confront the world until I've had at
least three cups of coffee cereal a nap
and luck
Shh they could deal with me cuz I'm not
do a shift for that also getting out of
bed is already struggle enough I have
enough [ __ ] to do before I even take the
covers off my face I gotta check
Instagram Twitter Facebook Instagram
again that's all stuff I got to do
before I even get out of bed before I
even open my eyes I gotta check all
those things my bed is like a warm
toasty oven and I'm the delicate flaky
pastry inside you wouldn't take a
delicate flaky pastry out of his warm
toasty oven while he's in there being
all warm and delicious and flaky
no you wouldn't you'd let him sit in
there you would let him be why get out
of bed when you just lay there forever
until you shrivel and die next morning
people are just the worst they're just
the get worse congratulations you got up
at 6 a.m. and flailed your sweaty thighs
to an 80s workout DVD
well I faced my pillow for an extra
three hours well joke's on you because
me sleeping is better than anything
you'll do with your whole skin life
while you're awake okay
also morning people are always saying
how much can [ __ ] they could get done
before everybody else wakes up oh I can
go the bank I can mail all my letters I
clean my apartment that's what I always
say you know what I clean my apartment
three minutes before anyone comes over
you know Stan a drunken naked sweaty
hurricane closer go everywhere my ass oh
so you know not the damn morning that's
for damn sure
finally everything is just better at
night even breakfast is better at night
you think I want to eat breakfast while
the Sun is out when everybody can see me
Jam it a whole waffle into my face while
hot syrup runs down my chin I want to
eat my waffles in the cover of darkness
under the moon like a hungry waffle
jackal just Hallett in the night in
conclusion mornings are flip [ __ ]
and I don't have to deal with it if I
don't want to so you could go right off
mornings alright everybody thank you for
watching this week as always you can
find our videos every week on
whineaboutit.tumblr.com in my page which
is facebook.com/buzzfeedmatt and you
find our videos on youtube i BuzzFeed
video and that's a that's everything
that's all Mitch spec time I go back to
bed I think boom said we're done turn it
off
did you turn it off no okay think we're
done
sure I don't know maybe I'll get funny
you never know
yet never now